can I get more pessimistic probably sure
so we just hurt you can we generally
don't please don't we just had the
Supreme Court I'm not trying to tell you
to be more pessimistic no no let's let's
stay where we were I'm sorry I've said
anything let's let's go back to where we
were and go we just had the Supreme
Court Rule that's half of Oklahoma's a
Native American reservation based on in
1866 treaty yeah because of the
left-leaning justices but as well as
Neel gorsek Gore said sure that course
such or such now we have this socialist
Seattle Councilwoman overthrow racist
sexist violent utterly bankrupt system
of capitalism but she's basically making
a reference to the entirety of the
country like she wants to only just read
this quote for you please do so this is
the Seattle City Councilman said we are
coming for you and your rotten system we
are coming to dismantle this deeply
oppressive racist sexist violent utterly
bankrupt system of capitalism this
police state we cannot and will not stop
until we overthrow it and replace it
with a world based instead on solidarity
genuine democracy and equality a
socialist world okay there's a lot there
I don't even know where to start
I I'm at a loss the you know what I'll
bring it back to what we were just
talking about earlier all right how most
people are not racist right most people
don't fit that category that they're
talking about where does it just go can
you bring that back I just want to break
it down this deeply offend pressive yeah
yeah this deeply oppressive racist
sexist violent utterly bankrupt system
of capitalism where is this world
they're living in where what I don't I
it's it's like we were talking about
they're they're getting these ideas from
movies and the you know because there's
always a bad guy there's always this
crazy story and it's like I'm not saying
that the racist people don't exist they
can they can f off I for lack of being
able to say the word I want to say right
now but I most people think that the you
know this this world that they claim
America is I know they are
ridiculous clearly they said it right
and but what a socialist world the goal
is to use something that you are
offended by mm-hmm racism you know and
then say you oppose racism right yes
well capitalism is racist right well I
would have say it I would say no oh but
it totally is how come how come so many
poor communities are mostly minority
communities I proved it I would say that
we don't teach our kids to be
superhumans
you know we teach them how to fall in
line you know and we most people we're
seeing the effects of that now as people
make it nowhere near that and when these
people show up and say did you know that
majority of the impoverished communities
in big cities are you know minority they
go oh because of racism and they go oh
there's nothing to do with bu in a city
you hate racism right yes then you need
to abolish capitalism and they go oh
that's it
none of one thing I've known for people
are white one thing I've learned on this
job is nothing is that easy and when
they try anyone tries to claim oh this
whole big complex issue is simply
because of this and we could just get
rid of it by switching to this and it's
like that is nonsense everything is is
super complex I every every day I learn
more and more and I feel further and
further away from what the the entirety
of everything because every day I
realize how complex the system we're
living in is nobody I am not even an
expert and I'm like bombarding my brain
about how how to understand all this
guaranteed none of these people are
experts either they're just claiming
they have the answers we want power that
when they just found a way to exploit
thank owner ability you're absolutely
right or good will most people are not
racist mm-hmm so most people will oppose
racism you know so then they come to you
and they say but look at all these these
examples of racism they take certain
stories out of context to manipulate you
that way you in the end
socialism yeah because that's their real
goal they don't care about minorities in
fact dare I say Karl Marx was a racist
and they themselves are extremely racist
yet like men extremely racist people
I've ever met my goodness I've never
seen more racism than I
have in the past four months from these
people on the left fighting against
racism
seriously well you gotta correct that
statement how so
claiming to fight against racism okay
good point right yes claiming you know
they're not doing that you're absolutely
right and you know what I think part of
the problem Marcellus Wiley said this he
awesome amazing I love him he's great
solid voice smart knowledgeable but he
said this recently he said one of the
problems is everybody has access to a
platform you know and and people who
have the loudest voice they're they tend
to be ignorant of the like kind of what
I was just saying everything so complex
you can't just claim you know the
answers and if if someone doesn't agree
with you because they might know more
about a complex system part of it
than you and you know they just get
upset but people have this platform and
they're using it and you know they're
making statements that aren't fully
informed they are in ignorance in the in
the classic sense of it that they are
using it spouting it and almost
everybody does this now you know it's
just kind of like that's the issue all
these the list of things that that
person said is wrong with the world you
know it comes from all these different
people that probably are ignorant of
what's really going on in the world they
probably have no idea so the big
challenge right now is how do we create
a unified trust the journalism is dead
you know so what happens is I put out a
tweet my joke tweet said you know it's
sad when anyone loses their life we must
do better to teach people not to dance
on highways at night wearing all black
around a curve behind an obstruction and
a bunch of these lefties got really mad
saying that I was victim blaming one who
had been murdered right but she didn't
get murdered in response to this in
legally someone someone commented and
they said the guy literally drove around
barricades to get on the highway and
then sped into these protesters cops
haven't said that that's not true at all
yeah no one so I responded with does
anybody actually read the news and then
someone screamed grabbed [ __ ] was NPR
okay which was
just completely at odds with the video
evidence mhm and they said I did
did you I demand a correction and I said
I didn't just read NPR or The Washington
Post or the local news you know in
Seattle or watch all of those I did all
of these things yeah and what this says
is wrong mm-hmm but this is an actual
news article and you're just a guy on
Twitter so how do we get past that point
where they're reading fake news that's
just no one's done any work and they're
gonna tell me I'm wrong and they demand
a retraction and then they go around
screen grabbing this being like look how
dummy is he made this up see NPR said so
yeah and I'm like I took NPR Washington
Post ABC local at Fox Local and three
videos of the actual streamed woman got
hit I put them all together and said
that's what happened but they didn't do
that they just blindly follow the
journalist who just like scribbled some
nonsense
well someone on a platform that I saw
proved my narrative so I'm just gonna
run with that that's yep that's how they
do it it's the easiest thing to do
exactly I can't tell you how many times
they'll bake a story and I'll go like
whoa the story is crazy and I'm thinking
like man I can't let this happening now
before I actually sit down and decide to
do a segment on this let me do some
fact-checking and it's not true and
bleep yep every day several times
I'll see someone tweet out something
like did you hear this mm-hmm and then
I'll be like whoa and I'll start digging
into it and be like wrong well and I
think that gives me max well yeah
people started saying that this user on
reddit was Ghislaine max well the the
you know the second in command to
Epstein it's crazy and they were like
look at this pattern of posting and all
this stuff and then I was like I saw a
bunch of conservatives tweeting like
whoa this is crazy and like retweeting
this thread and I'm like there's no
proof this is Maxwell what is this
because the because the users name was
like Maxwell Hill okay it's one of the
most prominent reddit users and then
someone immediately responded Maxwell
Hill is a place in Malaysia
please stop this and then the user
action started posting like I can't I
don't have no idea what's going on oh
wow they try it this is the after she
got arrested yeah so that they were
saying that as soon as she got arrested
the post stopped okay and sure you can
argue it's a truck it's a conspiracy
and then once they realized people knew
it was her
someone logged in and then said nope
nope I'm still here when it really was
her whatever fine there's no evidence to
suggest it was actually her and I saw a
ton of high profile people posting this
so I won't post it yeah I won't i won't
even I don't even bring it up unless
it's to point out no confirmation I have
the best situation here I'm doing all
this research people are hitting me up
giving me ideas it's sending me this
stuff that's crazy I'm like whoa this is
insane
yo Tim is this true nope nuts er no I'm
like oh no not that one
thanks there was a couple there's a
couple where you're like hey did you
hear this I'm like I don't think that's
true because of this and you go let me
check oh wait I think I found it now I'm
like oh wow really yeah well there's
been a few times so it's pretty good the
the black lives matter woman saying that
you know talking smack about white
people yep I thought it because was a
screengrab
mm-hmm that I was like I know I know
that you know for those aren't from of
the story a high profile member of black
lives matter and I think Toronto Toronto
yeah said things about white people that
I probably can't repeat on YouTube about
you know positioning in ranking the
racist to put it that way right yes that
superiority inferiority stuff and I know
that that black lives matter had said
something like this before that went
viral mm-hmm so when the story popped up
again and all people were sharing were
screenshots I didn't believe it and I
was like no one's actually posted any
hard source it turns out the post was
really old but it was the it was a it
was legit I think it was like three
years old or something yeah back in 2017
but so that the problem we face now is
that it's all noise and you know I think
might be happening with these polls and
with Trump and the election all that
stuff you have a journalist I'll do air
quotes thank you
they're sitting in their office and they
have like a you know like like like most
of them their eyes are rolled to the
back of their head and they're just like
drooling oh yeah and then someone walks
in and goes right Trump bad and they go
okay and they start mashing the keys and
then just like they have like you know a
dozen you know chimps in a room while
mashing the keys and eventually orange
man bad pops up yeah when they write
that nonsensical story then they publish
it it goes then there's another news
room where you have the same people
sitting there drooling and then they see
the article pop up and it says Trump
stole a scoop of ice cream and they go
Donald Trump is a thief he was caught
stealing you know Donald Trump was gonna
steal from everybody and now they've
taken this and use it as pretext write
another article right Donald Trump is a
thief confirmed thence another
journalist drooling in their office you
know seized um-hum Bert's a thief in the
go how long has Donald Trump been
stealing from the poor and it just keeps
spinning around in circles the
mainstream media telephone network right
if you will so let's say the first you
know person sees a poll that says will
Trump you know be triumphant in November
and it says it's a neck-and-neck race
between Trump and Biden and they go whoa
so Trump might actually lose the article
is saying that our this poll comes out
saying Trump does have a decent
probability of losing so they write
Trump could actually lose this election
send another journalist sees it Trump is
losing whoa Trump is losing send you
know and someone writes whoa Trump is
losing Trump has no chance send the next
person sees that Trump has no chance
it's over for Trump he's panicking send
and the last one is Donald Trump
floundering administration is panicked
and then a journalist calls someone
working with Trump and goes is it true
that you're all in a freefall panic that
everything is falling apart around you
your lives are over and Trump's house
burned down no no and even better the
Republicans are thinking of dropping
Trump yep that is an actual thing I read
that and then going at the same time
that story comes out where it's like
Republican Republicans discussed Trump
dropping out political rights Trump
admits it he's losing and then actual
quote from Trump we're expecting a
really huge win when the silent majority
steps up it's going to be historical a
lot and I'm like what the exact opposite
what am I supposed to trust your top
secret anonymous sources or the words of
the man himself right I have I have no
reason listen I understand some people
don't like Trump some people do like
them like him I don't care if you like
him or don't like him yeah if it came
down to it and and Ian said yo Tim Adam
wants to eat a cheeseburger
I'd be like what strange items vegan and
then it came to you and said Adam do you
what do you eat for it for lunch and you
said a vegan cheeseburger I'd be like
I'll take your word for it yeah you said
those words why would I be like I don't
know
no no Ian said you wanted a regular
cheeseburger well
technically I would just say
cheeseburger I would say I wouldn't add
one I would I would know what you meant
this reminds me of their I camera it was
an episode of Family Guy and someone I
care about it was about someone stole
Peter's phone or something okay and then
texted Joe like I'm gonna go to
build-a-bear with you and then Peter was
like I don't want to go and he was I
don't know it says right here on the
phone you said you wanted to come with
me and he's like no no I I don't want to
go then his phone rings and goes mmm
nope says you do so then they go and
then peers like can I leave and he goes
well you just texted me again saying you
want to stay so like that was the joke
like somebody was texting him pretend to
be Peter and Joe's like no I don't know
like I know you're telling me but I see
this text yeah we literally are in a
world where journalists will go to
Donald Trump and be like mr. Trump
what's your favorite kind of pizza and
he'll go I really love pan with a nice
oily Parmesan crust and then they'll go
but anonymous sources say Trump actually
likes deep dish confirmed the man
literally told you what he was doing
right it's the craziest thing that we
live where we are in this era what how
am I supposed to you know I got I got
something for you a poll was released in
March from CBS okay and it found that
Americans trust Trump more than the
mainstream media think about how bad the
media has to do for people to prefer to
trust a real estate reality TV mogul
well I mean he won he won he's the
president newsflash if you don't like
him and you don't you're trying to deny
it he is the president and that proves
people like listening to what he has to
say so people go out and watch his
speeches it's online they can listen to
the man himself the media is so bad at
what they do
yep that more Americans would trust a
reality TV real estate mogul than an
actual 20-year career veteran journalist
amazing yep it says a lot doesn't it yes
it does
Matt you go on listen to Trump and and
and it's an it's an issue of Trump
saying something like you know he'll go
up and go
really like deep-dish pizza it's
fantastic and then the press writes
Donald Trump hates all pizza you're like
if you know no Donald Trump hates
Chicago yeah no no Donald Trump
culturally-appropriate Italians yeah
right but it's the the actual real
example if Donald Trump giving a speech
where he said we're gonna build a great
garden of Heroes everybody loves it it's
the best Amelia Earhart Harriet Tubman
and then Brookings Institute ghosts
Trump wants to build Trump Trump calls
Confederate soldiers heroes and it's
like when did that it wet yeah well
right well it's because he was talking
about the forefathers yeah and they
extrapolated that to mean Confederate
yeah well sure they lied right
absolutely a hundred percent they did
yes
um III most people listen to him speak
so when they see the mainstream
narrative and they're like that's
ridiculous I listened to what he said
over and over and over for four years
what do they think is gonna happen
people are gonna be they're gonna be
Thank You Greta is it gonna be Hillary
Clinton is it gonna be Heather did you
see her her speech about how she would
email female presidents have handled the
coronavirus the best on the world so
wink wing well done I noticed something
else would you notice new haircut new
haircut bagel smile Botox light colors
yep
pleasant Pleasant cheery demeanor funny
said yeah Sun setting did I did I jinx
us like four months ago
what biden said he was gonna pick a
woman ii that left the words left the
his mouth I was like Hillary Clinton hmm
Biden she's gonna take you out the
moment the moment he says it a moment he
says it every single media outlet will
start praising Hillary Clinton they're
gonna be a lie about this has been a
disaster our economy is in ruins it's
about time we we went back to 2016 and
made the right choice but that is not
democracy they are they are throwing it
in people's faces we don't care what you
think we don't care about your vote or
they only care about your vote we don't
care what you think though
we didn't have to send her to debate and
show you why she would be a good
president we're just gonna shove it down
your throat that she's gonna be the one
for you it's like ah gross there there's
gonna be terrible they're gonna they're
already saying this the memes are
popping up or they're like I thought the
Trump presidency would be bad I didn't
realize it would be this bad the economy
is in ruins people are dying I'm gonna
move ISM it's been amazing when do they
talk and they wait till the eleventh
hour when it mattered most yep they they
I mean look I think I shall have a tweet
here to show you guys they waited until
the very last minute to exploit whatever
they could exploit so take a look take a
look this tweet from dr. David Samadi
please explain to me why mandatory masks
were not implemented around March 22nd
if they were serious about stopping the
spread if they were thought to be
effective they should have been used
from day one implementing implementing
them at this point does next to nothing
take a look at this figure four
confirmed deaths among Kovach cases by
death by date of death Ontario March 1st
to July 5th look at this mandatory masks
implemented yep and there's almost no
deaths
yeah after it took out all the people
that were immunocompromised that were
already on the verge of with other
pre-existing conditions so yeah makes
sense but why would they make it
mandatory after the fact why I have no
idea man 11 11th hour exploitation of a
crisis take for political gain I mean
there was that tweet by aoc that is
contested I don't know if that's real I
didn't see the tweet myself I just want
I don't think it's real what which one
she basically yeah yeah I'll just say
there's tweets that are going around
that basically was this the one wish
that closed the businesses yeah no I
know I know it's uh it's condesa mad
people are saying I saw it for myself I
don't know I didn't see it but you got
to think about it though the tweet being
fake is regardless it doesn't matter I'm
not talking about the tweet itself being
fake I'm talking about the fact that
they are clearly happy the economy is
now tanking that now they're talking
about it now they're blaming Trump for
the economy tanking but it's actually
because they're doing kovat 19 and the
business is not opening up again so
they really do feel like most people are
idiots they're exploiting the the crisis
yep so I thought I thought about this
because people have talked about the
right flight as people in the know flee
the cities okay
regular people aren't gonna flee the
cities they not paying attention that's
that's probably true and so the cities
are gonna become a bunch of NPCs and the
resistance the people who oppose these
Democrats will leave giving them
guaranteed power for the next however
long man that's a good erase another
good point yeah that's the solidifying
their their win over the cities that
some live now
so here's gonna happen some liberal
types are gonna leave because they're
rich most conservative types of moderate
types will leave because they're more
industrious and then the people without
the capability to move and the people
who don't pay attention will stay giving
them the politically uninitiated and the
poor yeah and those are the people who
work on a vote Democrat guaranteeing no
competition in these jurisdictions for
Congress man the more I look into the
policies that they've put I scratch your
head yeah yeah but you know you know the
way we're not Republican well I I'm
definitely a lot more conservative than
I probably probably be aligned with the
libertarian party probably that's true
yeah Liberty Libertarian Party has
always had fiscally conservative
policies but socially liberal in a sense
not not completely okay but basically
the libertarian party was more like hey
let's not have the government spend all
our money on dumb war stuff let's let
people live and let and do their thing
and that includes there's a really funny
shirt that says I camera board it says
maybe you know what I'm talking about
the one where it's like I just want to
smoke pot with oh yeah I got to be able
to protect my pot plants with my
automatic weapon for my like with my gay
neighbors yeah but if like basically the
Democratic Party is gun control the
Republican Party is pro-life but this is
changing man you notice I think it's
changing I think the Republic I think
everything was just shifted dramatically
to the left you know when you look at
now Jeff Andrew is a good example he's
got 100 percent rating from Planned
Parenthood's my understanding and he's a
Republican he switch parties and he won
the primary so here's a guy who's Pro
choice and he was a conservative
Democrat so he's probably the furthest
left Republican there is but the whole
Republican Party is gonna move left in a
ton of issues think about every single
conservative like not everybody you know
ninety percent supporting aa police
reform as it pertains to like George
Floyd yeah that's in my opinion unheard
of ten years ago there was the launch of
blue lives matter and you know back to
blue and defend defend the police and
stuff which it which is it's still
around today for sure yeah but I was
surprised that when George Floyd died
even Rush Limbaugh and Hannity they came
out and they're like this is wrong it's
terrible yeah there's a big and this is
a cultural leftward push a lot of people
said what does that mean how does it
left there's economic left and there's
the cultural left there's the economic
right in the cultural right the
important thing that one needs to know
not like when it comes to any political
faction be it far-right I'm doing air
quotes or far-left they're all
economically left all of them okay
the only economically right meaning
laissez-faire capitalism is like
libertarians and and caps but even among
what the what what the press calls far
right is actually economically far left
advocating for universal health care
government programs just for you know
their people mm-hmm you know so yeah I
don't know nothing seems to make sense
at this point anyway so I don't even
with the point is yeah right thanks for
checking out this clip from the Tim cast
IRL podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you